так дзвони та візаві закони українські
депутати піщаних daleks про тата чола
хвали ось їм аль-асад у європейських
колег за втратимо
верховна рада година петра порошенка
малюками дражнячи йти в дроби частини
віктора януковича русування євро
депутати Верховної Ради
верховної ради просто нас приймають
закони та кнопки дні коло і для
лібералізації візового режиму
він і до півночі що буде прийнято
політичне рішення не ціни так ми
читаємо вона конкретніше верховною радою
закон quick access ось виявити i'm from
Верховна Рада
у хвала не візових законів у ціна тільки
інший стиль ким вузли віз для українців
їздить це Європи без віз з адаптація
закону дарства до європейських стандартів
ви провал на глушити експерти вони але
кожен якші виконані таємниця верховну
раді табір і відразу милу щоб а то
депутатів блоку йти закони
що вона хоче створ це механізми боротьби
з корупцією
а от і хочеш ще гуси в україні
маллорі дніпрова за крима та секс машини
со означає що у ній ньому якщо крипи
треба європейських цінностей
точно словами євроінтеграції акули до
праворуч саботаж пари hit with a past
радянські моделі тримаючи водою європейську
можна лише з повернути всім аевіт
класи типу вражають у брюсселем та турі
київ знову pc usb перепливу Москви